eighty percent of the british population
say they visit a fish and chip shop at
least once a year
and we consume 382 million meals from
the chippy per annum
that's pretty impressive for a
combination that's only been with us for
around 150 years
for the first fish and chip shop only
appeared in around 1860.
separately both fried fish and chips
were enjoyed by the british well before
they came together
chips as a term for something edible was
in use in the 18th century
often in relation rather curiously to
oranges
orange chips for candied chunks of peel
it was in the same century that the
potato was going from knobbly curiosity
to staple food
especially for the poor and given how
well potatoes lend themselves to deep
frying
it was inescapable that potato chips
would soon be on the scene
by the victorian era chipped potatoes
were everywhere
from the delicate little straw potatoes
which resembled
well straw eaten by the rich to the
french street food which dickens
described as husky chips of potatoes
fried with some reluctant drops of oil
the british preferred baked potatoes but
they ate them fried too
fried fish meanwhile was also on the
tables of the rich and the poor
breadcrumbed fillets delicately fried in
butter and garnish with fried parsley
were a staple for upmarket meals
white bait fried in lard were considered
a delicious delicacy
but there was another place fried fish
could be bought and that was the street
in the jewish quarters of london and
other big cities there sephardic jews
sold cold fried fish intended for eating
on the sabbath when no cooking was
allowed in jewish homes
it quickly took off being cheap filling
and tasty
and fried fish shops and market stalls
hot and cold
sprung up in cities across the uk it was
inevitable that these two street foods
so popular in the masses would end up
being sold in combination
it proved a winning formula and fish and
chip shops took off
immediately trawl fishing and the
railway boom of the 1870s helped fish to
reach inland
areas quicker than ever before and
potatoes were already grown everywhere
by 1910 there were 25 000 fish and chip
shops in the uk
and by 1929 there were ten thousand more
such was the hold of fish and chips and
its genuine goodness especially for its
mainly working class consumers
that during the second world war fish
and chips remained off the ration
though the type of fish available was
not always the most delicious or
desirable of species
across the uk accompaniments vary from
the mushy peas of the north to curry
sauce ketchup mayonnaise or the chip
shop spice which is on every counter in
whole
salt and vinegar remain the staples in
the 21st century chippies vegetable fats
have often replaced beef dripping or
lard for frying
newspaper used to be the wrapping of
choice outlawed unless
fresh from the printers and unsullied by
reader's hands in 1968.
now it's mainly plain paper and
polystyrene but the skillful wrapping
and excitement of
unwrapping remains there are however
fish and chips
and fish and chips witness the
disappointment on the faces of tourists
lured by the promise of a great british
delicacy only to find they've happened
upon the bad version
all grease and soggy batter but then
when it's good
well it's crispy and fluffy with a hit
of vinegar and the punch of salt
it's unbeatable thanks for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video